>>> JOINING US NOW IS DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN PRAMILA JAYAPAL OF
WASHINGTON, THE CHAIR OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL PROGRESSIVE
CAUCUS.
SHE ALSO SERVES ON THE HOUSE
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US THIS MORNING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
DEAL?
>> GOOD MORNING, BRIANNA.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY,
VERY MAJOR STEP FORWARD IF WE
CAN GET IT DONE AND I BELIEVE WE
CAN, I BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
REAL DEAL HERE.
YOU KNOW, LOOK, IT'S DIFFICULT
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A YEAR OF
NEGOTIATIONS, ONE STEP FORWARD,
FOUR STEPS BACK, BUT I THINK WE
ARE NOW VERY, VERY CLOSE, AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S IN THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY
A MAJOR ACCOMPLISHMENT, WILL
HELP AMERICANS BRING COSTS DOWN,
WILL ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING THE PLANET FOR OUR
NEXT GENERATION AND WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE'S HEALTH CARE
IS COVERED INSTEAD OF BEING CUT
OFF IN THE NEXT, YOU KNOW, 30
DAYS ESSENTIALLY WHEN THOSE
SUBSIDIES EXPIRE FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN.
SO THIS IS A MASSIVE STEP
FORWARD AND I'M EXCITED TO SEE
THE NEXT PIECES OF IT, INCLUDING
THE FULL TEXT AND THE PROCESS
GOING FORWARD.
>> TWO WEEKS AGO THE NARRATIVE
WAS SO DIFFERENT, RIGHT?
IT WAS THAT MANCHIN HAD PULLED
ONE OVER ON SCHUMER AND ANY SORT
OF DEAL WAS DEAD, AND YOU HAVE
BEEN HYPERCRITICAL OF JOE
MANCHIN.
YOU ACTUALLY CALLED HIM NOT A
REAL DEMOCRAT AT ONE POINT.
DOES THIS CHANGE YOUR
ASSESSMENT?
>> WELL, LOOK, ON CAPITOL HILL
THINGS CHANGE ALL THE TIME AND I
FOUND THAT TO BE SUCCESSFUL WHAT
YOU HAVE TO DO IS YOU HAVE TO
ROLL WITH WHATEVER COMES YOUR
WAY.
IF WE CAN GET THIS DONE IT WILL
BE A MASSIVE STEP FORWARD FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND, YOU
KNOW, I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE TO FOCUS ON.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY NOW TO
MAKE HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN
CLIMATE, IN HEALTH CARE, IN
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICING.
I MEAN, NOTHING WE HAVE EVER
DONE BEFORE HAS ALLOWED MEDICARE
TO NEGOTIATE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
SO WHILE THERE IS A LOT THAT WAS
LEFT ON THE CUTTING ROOM FLOOR,
THE REALITY IS THIS WOULD BE A
MASSIVE ACCOMPLISHMENT AND IT
WOULD HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> IF YOU GET THIS DONE, DOES
THAT MAKE JOE MANCHIN A REAL
DEMOCRAT IN YOUR EYES?
>> WELL, LOOK, I WORKED WITH JOE
MANCHIN MANY TIMES OVER THE LAST
YEAR.
I STILL THINK THAT HAD WE DONE
THIS BACK IN DECEMBER, HAD WE
DONE THE ENTIRETY OF THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA WE WOULD BE
IN BETTER SHAPE, BUT AM I HAPPY
THAT JOE MANCHIN IS AT THE TABLE
RIGHT NOW?
ABSOLUTELY.
WELCOME IN, JOE MANCHIN.
DELIGHTED TO WORK WITH YOU TO
GET THIS DONE.
LET'S GET SOMETHING DONE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HURTING FOR WAY
TOO LONG AND I THINK THAT'S THE
STEP THAT WE ARE AT NOW IS LET'S
MOVE THIS FORWARD, WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK WE HAVE TO DO, WE NEED
TO SHOW DEMOCRATS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY THAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY CAN ACTUALLY GET STUFF
DONE WHEN WE HAVE 50 DEMOCRATS
IN THE SENATE AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
SO I'M ALL ABOUT
FORWARD-LOOKING, BRIANNA, AND
HELLO, JOE MANCHIN.
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU.
>> SO ON A SEPARATE TOPIC HERE,
A MAN ACCUSED OF HATE CRIMES AND
ACCUSED OF THREATENING TO KILL
YOU AFTER SHOWING UP AT YOUR
HOUSE VERY LATE AT NIGHT AND
YELLING OBSCENITIES OUTSIDE HAS
BEEN CHARGED WITH FELONY
STALKING, WHICH SOUNDS
INCREDIBLY SCARY FOR YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY.
YOU ALSO WERE ONE OF 27
DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED AGAINST
EXPANDED SECURITY FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS OF SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
IN LIGHT OF THIS INCIDENT THAT
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY HAVE
EXPERIENCED, WHAT IS YOUR VIEW
ON HOW FAMILIES OF OFFICIALS
NEED TO BE PROTECTED IN THIS
HYPER CHARGED POLITICAL CLIMATE?
>> WELL, I'VE NEVER BELIEVED
THAT ANY PROTESTERS, ANY
VIOLENCE, SHOULD HAPPEN AGAINST
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND WHETHER
THAT'S A REPUBLICAN OR A
DEMOCRAT, SOMEBODY WHO AGREES
WITH ME OR NOT, AND I THINK THE
HOME IS A SACRED PLACE.
THE REASON FOR MY VOTE ON THE
SUPREME COURT BILL WAS BECAUSE I
WANTED THAT BILL TO ALSO COVER
THE STAFF OF THE SUPREME COURT
AND FEDERAL JUDGES, AND FRANKLY
I THINK WE NEED A LOT MORE FUNDS
IN CONGRESS TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT SOME OF US.
YOU KNOW, THE THREAT ASSESSMENT
THAT'S BEEN DONE AT MY HOME WILL
REQUIRE A LOT OF CHANGES IN MY
HOUSE AND CURRENTLY THERE ISN'T
SUFFICIENT FUNDS TO SUPPORT
THAT.
SO MY BEEF WITH THAT BILL, IF
YOU WILL, WAS THAT IT REALLY
NEEDS TO GO FURTHER.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
ELECTED OFFICIAL AND THE STAFF
THAT WORK WITH US -- I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THIS HAS BEEN REALLY
SCARY FOR MY STAFF AS WELL
BECAUSE THIS MAN HAS SENT
LETTER -- A LETTER, AT LEAST
THAT WE KNOW OF, TO THE OFFICE
AND HE HAS BEEN STALKING ME FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS.
SO I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
PROSECUTOR FOR MOVING THE
CHARGES FORWARD.
IT'S A VERY HIGH BAIL AMOUNT,
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
I DON'T THINK IN ANY WAY, SHAPE
OR FORM THAT THIS KIND OF
VIOLENCE CAN BE CONDONED OR
FUELED AGAINST ANY ELECTED
OFFICIAL AND UNFORTUNATELY
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS BIG LIE AND
THE VIOLENCE THAT HE INCITED AND
ENCOURAGED IS PART OF WHAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE QUOTING WHEN THEY
COME AND THREATING US AT OUR
DOORS WITH GUNS.
THAT IS JUST UNACCEPTABLE.
SO WE'VE UNLEASHED SOMETHING,
THANKS TO DONALD TRUMP, WE WILL
HAVE TO TRY TO REEL IT BACK AND
ONE OF THE WAYS TO DO THAT IS TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE AWAY THE TOOLS
OF PEOPLE ABLE TO HAVE GUNS.
BECAUSE WE FILED AN EXTREME RISK
ORDER WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
REMOVE HIS GUN AS WELL AS THE
GUN THAT HE HAD ACCESS TO IN HIS
HOME, BUT HE SAYS HE WANTED TO
GO OUT AND BUY AN ASSAULT RIFLE
AND COME BACK TO MY HOUSE AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THAT SIMPLY IS NOT THE WAY
THAT -- WE SIMPLY CAN'T ALLOW
THAT.
AND SO I'M GRATEFUL THAT THE
CHARGES ARE MOVING FORWARD.
>> THE DCCC, THE CAMPAIGN ARM OF
HOUSE DEMOCRATS AND ALSO OTHER
DEMOCRATIC GROUPS, HAS BEEN
SPENDING PRETTY BIG MONEY TRYING
TO BOLSTER ELECTION DENIERS IN
GOP PRIMARIES.
SO CHALLENGERS TO THE RIGHT OF
MORE MAINSTREAM REPUBLICAN
INCUMBENTS, AND THAT INCLUDES
PEOPLE LIKE CONGRESSMAN MEIJER
WHO VOTED TO IMPEACH DONALD
TRUMP.
HERE IS WHAT REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINZINGER WHO
IS OBVIOUSLY A PART OF THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE SAID ABOUT
THAT.
>> DON'T COME TO ME AFTER HAVING
SPENT MONEY SUPPORTING AN
ELECTION DENIER IN A PRIMARY AND
THEN COME TO ME AND SAY, WHERE
ARE ALL THE GOOD REPUBLICANS?
YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
DEMOCRACY.
>> WHERE DO YOU FALL ON THIS
ISSUE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I HAVEN'T
SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON IT BUT I
WAS ASKED ABOUT IT YESTERDAY,
AND WHAT I WILL SAY IS I HAVEN'T
LOOKED AT THE RACE.
I'M UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE IDEA
OF BOOSTING ELECTION DENIERS.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO BE ABOUT
PEOPLE OVER POLITICS AND I THINK
AT THE END OF THE DAY THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO NOT SORT OF
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE WHO ARE DENYING
THE ELECTION.
AT THE SAME TIME I THINK THAT
THERE IS A RECORD SEPARATE FROM
IMPEACHMENT THAT PEOPLE HAVE ON
ROE v. WADE, ON OTHER THINGS,
AND I THINK THAT THAT RECORD OF
THE CANDIDATES IN THE RACE, THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES IN THE
RACE, THERE IS A REAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THOSE CANDIDATES AND OUR
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE IN THAT
RACE, HILLARY SHULTEN, I THINK
WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
THOSE DIFFERENCES AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE LIFTING UP ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT HILLARY IS GOING TO
BRING AS A DEMOCRAT TO THIS --
TO THAT DISTRICT AND TO CONGRESS
AT THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TIME WHEN PEOPLE'S RIGHTS ARE AT
STAKE.
IT'S NOT MY STRATEGY.
LISTEN, I WAS SOMEBODY WHO
THOUGHT THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
GOING TO WIN WHEN EVERYBODY ELSE
IN 2016 WAS SAYING THERE IS NO
WAY HE CAN WIN.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT ASSUMING THAT WE
CAN CONTROL WHAT VOTERS DO AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
I JUST DON'T -- I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S THE STRATEGY I WOULD
TAKE.
I DON'T WANT TO SECOND-GUESS THE
D TRIP, I HAVEN'T LOOKED INTO
THIS RACE, BUT THAT'S MY
REACTION.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING.